what's happening reject nation i'm greg
i'm john
we're gonna watch the official trailer
for this is
the year super excited to check this out
some of you guys might know why
recently had writer and director of this
is the year star of wizards of waverly
place
david henry up here on the channel
they're having a
live premiere event on august 28th two
dollars off with promo code
rejects if you guys want to uh check out
the film there a lot of famous people
will be involved including selena gomez
and a bunch of other people the video
with david was a total blast as you can
see by all this footage and i'm playing
over me talking
oh my god look how much laughs we're
having together we did a
reaction together to the promo event
commercial that was released on sena
gomez's page and then i just
interviewed him and asked him a whole
bunch of questions we met david way back
in eighth grade so
uh we have a history together but i
really think you guys would love that
video so please go check it out really
get a lot of in-depth perspective and a
lot of
funny conversation in regards to
this is the year you know some wizard
stuff anywho let's check this out
hey guys i'm back with david henry and
we're so excited to reveal the trailer
for this
is the year so check out the trailer now
and get tickets for our exclusive
live so sick of seeing your face on
august 28th and this is the year
hey david well you'll watch the movies
[Music]
you're josh right
[Music]
i literally have no plan maybe you just
want frenzo
do you like me oh she didn't see the guy
hello are you kidding me
[Music]
we would all lose to greg sulkin paige
is answering the question
how was your high school experience but
but a lot of interesting things can
happen in the next three weeks i'm
talking life-changing events that could
completely change my
school experience i have no idea what
you're talking about
we're closing out the question center
this year will be lovely the band
i was killed i love that the bands
playing themselves two minutes
dude that would have been a date to
remember
dude i'm seeing all those edgar wright
styles all the things we're talking
about that's crazy
all right you guys ready it's a road
trip
[Music]
dj this looks great i
sincerely mean that
[Music]
i've never been killed josh you guys
seem super close
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
zoe everything was finally going the way
i wanted and my life is a mess
of course your life's a mess you're a
[Music]
teenager
[Music]
wow
[Music]
who's he saying that too
which girl who's which girl
maybe the two girls end up together and
he is left out
maybe lorenzo's saying it to david and
it just gets
awkward maybe he's saying it to jeff
garland because that guy looks like he's
there for it looks great it's actually
fascinating to like
talk with david for so long and hear so
much of the
inspirations and the moods of what he
was going for
and like the directing styles i'm just
telling you to go watch that video
too because a lot of time you know like
we live in la you got people who are
always telling you their ideas what
they're going for and then you see
something
and granted this isn't the movie itself
this is just a trailer for
what the trailer's doing it sounds like
he's a hundred percent succeeding in
everything david was saying that he set
out to do
like you do see some of those edgar
wright shot transition
cut influences definitely on display and
yeah is it a simple
traditional plot like an 80s movie sure
but
for a movie like this i think a lot of
it has to do with execution and he does
talk a lot about flipping tropes on its
head within the
the interview that i did with him that
whole trope flipping on its head thing
i'm not seeing as much of a prevailing
presence specifically in this
trailer however all the stuff that i
think matters most is really here the
feel-good nature of it kind of like that
swept up in the
rom-com vibe like a juno that feels very
much
present here like this whole thing is
just advertising is like 20 20 hasn't
been that great let's flip it on its
head let's have a great
time this year with something special
this feels like that great sense of
escapism
feel good coming of age tale lorenzo
looks freaking awesome
yeah it looks great yeah i mean this
whole trailer just made me feel good
yeah
i mean a great sales pitch for a
feel-good movie and yeah i mean from
everything david was talking about it
seems like he's nailing it which is good
when a director is able to give you
their vision and then it shows up in the
trailer
yes i think these movies definitely come
down to just the chemistry of the cast
and how well you roll the wheel and i
mean yeah
i'm looking forward in the actual film
and seeing some of the subversions and
stuff take place because that's also how
you make you know
something that's a bit familiar more
unique but um yeah in terms of just
an independent movie trailer this looked
totally professional
it got me just swept up in the heart
swell of everything you know it got me
it got me right where it wants me yeah
it felt genuine it felt sincere and i
think that's
what to be honest if david happens to be
watching this video that was kind of
what my concern was when i was hearing
all these things
is if i was like is this gonna feel
sincere or is it gonna feel
like producer marketing notes of what
we're going for
and you know like a pandering like
experience and but this doesn't feel
that way
right now at least what the traders
communicate all performers look great
jeff garland's presence i'm really
excited about a big kirby enthusiasm fan
um and you know look anytime you can
look at greg sulkin why the hell not oh
yeah
plus now i'm just gonna be watching this
movie in any scene where lorenzo is just
covered with two close-ups and a wide
i'm just gonna assume that he directed
that
he guilted david shooting that scene
more simply so what was it like
directing lorenzo
was rebellious
he would just say things he would just
say things that you'd only say to a
brother
he'd be like do you really need this
much coverage
[Laughter]
i haven't seen lorenzo in years but i
can totally imagine that
he'd be like why are you getting all
these shots
it's like don't you just get it get a
wide and two close-ups let's move on
i was like why did i make you the
lorenzo i feel like vanessa murano and
lorenzo will have
great chemistry the two female leads
together like i was glad that we at
least got a little glimpse of their
friendship in this trailer because i
feel like it would be pretty easy to
only focus on lorenzo the love story the
protagonist stuff but it
kind of looked a bit more ensemble in
doing that
yeah i'm not sure about the uh like the
greg sulkin i forget the other actress
his name i apologize
uh the blonde girl the way the trailer
was pitching it like oh lorenzo's into
her
oh i got this hot british boyfriend you
know that that thing
and so what i imagine kind of like uh
forgetting sarah marshall to a certain
extent
because they're british yeah british and
you got a blonde girl you know so
that's where my mind went to at least
based off my discussion with david i
imagine it's gonna be more than
greg sulkin is total douche and she is
such a diva
you know yeah because that's kind of
what they do a lot of the time like oh
my god look at these two
guys she just doesn't see it
yeah yeah something about his
performance felt a little bit more uh
subtle he strikes me as the kind of
character that you'll be conflicted
about i mean he
certainly looked likeable it didn't give
me any reason to suspect that he's gonna
make a turn into being some kind of
villain by the end but it does look like
the kind of thing where you might be
like oh damn
i see why they're good together too but
i'm rooting for lorenzo yeah well it
seems to have a bit of more of a
grounded instead of cartoony approach to
a lot of this that's why i keep using
the word sincere and authentic because
this could have easily been like oh
lorenzo like dweeb and then [ __ ]
chris evans steps out of the car
yeah yeah like it seemed like they were
dialing it back to make it feel like
more believable
as opposed to slap sticky or like this
as a comedy you know
yeah yeah it's funny because even though
the tone is very apparent in this
trailer i also didn't feel like
beat around the head and neck with it as
you sometimes do in trailers that are
really trying to convince you of
something i feel like this bodes well to
me because this trailer didn't so much
feel like it was
trying to convince me of something it
rather just felt like
a genuine taste of what this experience
ought to be this is a weird position for
a different reason
because i i i'm trying to find like
actual criticisms about what i saw so i
don't look like a kiss ass
and the only thing i could find is i'm
not seeing too much of the subverting of
like major like really flippy things on
its head so much
but i'm like that's not even really a
criticism that's just more like what the
trailer is not really displaying for me
so much
and that stuff will probably be better
in the movie yeah
it's all about the execution why'd you
have to make such a solid trailer
couldn't you have thrown in some bad
coverage or something i need something
that's like oh
the sound was off there you know oh yeah
oh take it back to the drawing
oh these are right moments that popcorn
blast
unbelievable anyway guys what you think
of the trailer the original link is in
the description box
if you liked this trailer or you liked
our reaction or discussion hit the like
button on this video subscribe make sure
to check out that video with david
promo code rejects two dollars off
august 28th
live premiere live premiere whole cast
will be there and a couple of famous
tick tock people
yeah tick tock best thing in the world
get it while you can
last but not least
rosa parra thinking about it this the
title of this is called this is the year
sincerely i know we make a lot of
sarcastic shout outs
sincerely insert sarcastic check
today is no different today rosa's
life is falling apart miserably i think
she's been having a surprisingly
awesome killer year in a lot more ways
than ones i mean
every one of us has had some
difficulties to deal with some more than
others i'm sure you
you haven't been short of problematic
things to deal with as well
however i remember a time when you set
out on a journey to be like hey i want
to start talking more about film and
this was like
you know like a year and a half two
years ago where you just had this like
this hobby that you were feeling
passionate about i have your twitter
pulled up because i want to make sure i
get
all this down properly all you've been
mad should be uh to accomplish this year
you follow her at rose's reviews
username rosa hashtag
latinx lens uh she's chicana film
reviewer co-founder of latin and x lands
a member of hca critics
wfcc women the oaf fc
assistant editor at their league as well
she's joining all these groups she's
more critic verified than
we've ever been that's true
she's a champion for the progressive
movements in life
um rosa i'm honored to know you i hope
you're being safe right
now keep kicking ass this year say hi to
your family for me
love the hell out of you lady stark
[Music]
you